joining us on the line is candice owen
she of course is the commentator the
host of the candace owns show and the
author of the brand new book blackout
how black america can make its second
escape from the democratic plantation
destin for the top of the best otherwise
candace
great to talk to you good to speak to
you ben you got me in a lot of trouble
well i mean to be fair i feel like you
got you in a lot of trouble because
you said mean things about cardi b and
as we all know you are not allowed to
say mean things about cardi b in fact
even if you just read the lyrics of her
song that was enough to get me in
trouble like
at least you got in trouble for saying
what you thought about cardi b i got in
trouble for saying what i didn't think
about cardi b
i actually just read the lyrics to her
song and got trended for two days
but you went after cardi b and pointed
out that actually
cardi b is not a great interviewer and
apparently this is highly controversial
so why don't you tell us
for folks who missed it why don't you
recap the great candace owns versus
cardi b non-rap battle well first off
what's ironic is before we even shot
that sunday special you and i were
chatting and i'm like
i feel like it's either you or me that's
always trending about something
ridiculous then of course this little
area segment and
it just goes trending um but you know i
i felt that i was
honest in the interview with you and
said that you know she is illiterate she
proved that very quickly in the twitter
spot
nothing was spelled correctly um you
know and she had no idea what she was
talking about
in terms of politics and she probably
tried to be intellectual for one tweet
when she
when she suggested um you know that her
tax dollars weren't going to education
and made some comments about trump that
made entirely no sense and then she
immediately shifted to just
insults and name-calling which just
showed that she just she has had she has
no intellectual capacity
i mean in in one instagram video where
she was holding her
barbie doll she accused my husband who
is white um
he accused his father of being in the uk
ku klux klan
for those of you that know don't know my
father-in-law is in the house of lords
so she believes the house of lords
united stand which is quite
incredible um so you know she attacked
my unborn child
and said that if my unborn child thinks
that i have a
dry ap the opposite of a wa
you know it was just it was really
childish and ridiculous and i was just
saying look
joe biden used you and she just went and
proved every point that we made in the
interview
um that he went after someone that has
no intellectual capabilities
uh simply because she has a large
following so candace
you know this this obviously has some
broader ramifications for
for the political conversation that's
going on right now so you're obviously
one of the
creators of blexit about black americans
leaving the democratic party and moving
toward the republican party
cardi b is a democrat for reasons that
have yet to be ascertained
i remember praising her little rants
about where are my tax dollars going
when she started screaming about where
her tax dollars were going and then she
supported bernie sanders which
seemed like a a bit of a shift but as
you pointed out to cardi b you know
black americans
are allowed to not be democrats
especially when they examine the policy
you've been ripped up and down for
taking
that position over and over again so do
you foresee that in this upcoming
election
donald trump is going to win a shocking
number of black voters the polls seem to
show that he is going to win an
increased number of black voters
i have been saying for the last three
years 20 points in 2020. i think
i think trump is going to secure 20 of
the black vote and i think based on what
we're seeing
you know in the media with this
obsession with the race narrative uh the
left knows that
and then that's why they're sort of
getting all of these organizations to
capitulate
that's the black lives matter narrative
the nba um all of these players kneeling
and you know for the national anthem and
pretending that black americans
like like police officers represent an
existential threat to black america
um so i see in in all of the craziness
that's going on i see
i see desperation and i think what we're
possibly seeing is the last wheels of a
dying animal that is the democratic
party
yeah i think that one of the reasons
that people were so upset about both you
and me going after cardi b
is because the democrats have really
created a nature preserve in the
cultural community they really believe
that they have soul
control over every aspect of american
culture so when you call out cardi b
or when i say that rap is a bad song
which it is uh when you say any of these
things
then they feel very threatened by this
and you can see this in the new
standards for the oscars i don't know if
you've been following this controversy
yet candace
but the oscars recently as in last night
came out with new rules as of 2024
uh you actually have to fulfill certain
rules in order for your picture to be
eligible for best picture including
a certain level of black lgbtq or female
representation on screen
stories that feature black lgbtq or uh
i guess deaf people really this is
something in there uh on screen
or a certain number of background actors
or interns who are black lgbtq
female or or deaf or disabled in some
way
you know is there gonna be a backlash
culturally against
all of this because it does make things
rather boring
i mean not even rather boring just also
rather senseless like what are we gonna
you know picture old england and pretend
that there were a bunch of black and
lgbtq people walking around when you do
historical accounts of things and wars
that happened
i mean are we gonna pretend that during
the revolutionary war was all
african-american men fighting for the
country
it's foolishness you know what i mean
and it it again is a part of their
effort to continually erase
true history you know we understand of
course across the board that bad things
happened everywhere in the entire world
um but pretending that they didn't and
trying to not whitewash but actually
blackwash
um all of history um it's dangerous and
you know the 1619 project with the new
york times this all falls into the same
vein
of them just being completely detached
from reality and trying to detach the
rest of us
including you know the future future
american generations away from the
reality of what happened in this country
and candace on a broader level one of
the issues that has come up in in
the in the last week couple of weeks is
the critical race theory issue
and the democrats have been trying to
downplay this members the media have
been trying to downplay critical race
theory
uh and the reason that it's come up is
because it was actually being taught in
sort of these diversity trainings at the
federal
government level it's become incredibly
prevalent on american university
campuses critical race theory which is
the idea
effectively speaking that all
institutions in american life
are institutions of power and thus
institutions of historic
white supremacy uh we're seeing this
play out in america streets with
with all the violence and with the the
anti-police move by by the democrats
maybe can speak to exactly what the
black community's perspective
is on policing these i think there are a
lot of misnomers about what black
americans actually think about the cops
if you watch the media all you get is
the black americans think that the cops
are evil and racist and out to hurt them
and then when you look at the polls you
see that 81
of black americans actually want the
same number or more police in their
community
right i would say what the what the left
is working on right now is the younger
generation of black americans who are
actually growing up believing
um that police are dangerous and police
want to kill them because of this sort
of media brainwash that's going on in
propaganda on a mass scale
um so it's very alarming when you speak
to a young black child or you see those
videos where they say i'm scared to go
outside
because that's how much the media has
harped on this false narrative but in
terms of the older generation they're
smarter than that they've lived they
lived long enough they lived in those
neighborhoods they know who the real
threat is they know that
you know when you remove police officers
it's not like okay suddenly police
officers are gone it means that there's
a vacuum
and people that fill that vacuum tend to
be gangsters you know you're breeding a
world in which the bloods and the crips
come back into power and are running the
streets
and of course you remove police officers
i say the people that say
defund the police you might as well come
out right and say kill more black people
because it
means exactly the same thing and we're
seeing that across the board right now
if you look at any
major inner city there's a minimum of
150 percent increase in black deaths
um you know in shootings and deaths in
these inner cities because of this push
uh to defund police initiatives we're
assuming the candidate owns her new book
is blackout how and black american can
make its second escape from the
democratic
plantation of course she's host of the
candace own show so kenneth you've been
talking a lot about
both politics and culture when it comes
to the inequality issues in america
between
black and and white which is what we all
focus on we never focus on inequality
between white nation because
of course that would suggest that uh
perhaps not all
inequalities are driven by the system
maybe some inequalities are driven by
differences in personal choice
um but when we talk about curing some of
the inequalities between black and white
particularly in the economic and socio
economic sphere do you think that those
solutions are going to come more from
culture or do you think they're going to
come more from politics because
you and i discuss politics all day and
it seems like politicians are constantly
pledging they're going to fix these
problems
it seems to me that these these problems
are not fixable in the realm of politics
a lot of them
how exactly should we be spending our
time focusing on on bettering people's
lives more in the cultural sphere or
more in the political sphere
i say it's a joint effort you know i'm
very against uh welfare programs which i
believe
incentivize bad behavior and there are a
ton of government programs that
incentivize and encourage bad behavior
um and so in that effort even in talking
about the department of education
and what they're putting into the school
systems that's why the government can
take a step back from the things and the
ideologies that they're teaching black
america
but mostly it's cultural um we have to
fix it and i said this when i was on
your show
you know we have to fix this broken baby
mama culture at the same time that
we uplift and we celebrate artists that
talk about gats and guns and gangs and
strippers and
baby mamas and how many men you can
sleep with where at the same time we
complain and say
why does the public have this view of us
you know it's in our music it's what we
listen to
and um you know i wrote this in my book
that confucius
said a quote that if you want uh to
basically say if you want to assess
the morals of any society listen to its
music um if you take that quotation you
apply it to black america it's
terrifying to realize where we're at
we have to you know raise a more
respectable culture we have to stop
saying to young black kids that are
intelligent like what was said to me
when i was younger stop
acting white and people believe that um
these are values attributes of whiteness
when you when you speak proper english
when you work hard when you dress well
um and and that is that is kind of the
plague of black america and people like
me who aren't
people to say that and admit that get
attacked um we need to reassess our
heroes our idols
um and all that work has to come from
within and candace it is incredible how
much of this also comes from white
elites
the robin d'angelos the the white people
on college campuses who spend an awful
lot of time suggesting
that bad behavior is actually okay
behavior or good behavior
if it is if it is done
disproportionately in a minority
community even though
it is ineffectual behavior when done by
anybody i was pointing this out to my
wife the other day is that
across the board regardless of of race
right now our culture glorifies single
motherhood in an extraordinary way
my wife who decided to get married and
then wait several years before having
children until we could afford it until
we felt
that we could handle it and now we have
three beautiful kids
she's not a heroine in any of these
stories right she's a doctor who has
three children and was raising these
kids while she was in residency she's
not a hero in any way but if she'd
gotten knocked up at 17
and then had a kid and then been on
welfare regardless of race then she'd be
lionized by the culture and seen as some
sort of a heroic figure
what do we have to do to shift this
because i don't think it's purely a
racial issue it seems like there are a
lot of white folks pushing this too
right and we have to hire you know we
have to hire our expectations and that's
really what we're seeing and
that low bigotry of expectations we're
seeing the infantilizing of black
america especially but across the board
um but there is a focus on black america
like we should be expected to do nothing
ever
because 400 years ago we were slaves um
you know it's absolutely senseless and
we have we are right now living in a
land of opportunity
i think a lot of what i see is cowardice
i think most of these people are fearful
uh you and i both know it is not easy it
takes a lot of work day in and day out
to find success
um you fall down a lot of times you make
a lot of mistakes and it takes
you know a certain amount of character
and courage to keep moving forward but
right now these people are told you know
be fearful of success success is wrong
back away from that and that is
ultimately just a tremendous act of
societal cowardice where kids don't
really want to try anymore
um and you're absolutely right the
culture glorifies that
and there's so much wrong about that the
people that are behind that that know
that it's wrong and allow these people
to be given platforms pretended that
there's there's some level of normalcy
to it
um but i do think that people like you
and i are changing that
you know i think just the courageous
just having the courage to say no it's
wrong
right to say this song is bad to say no
cardi b should not be interviewing joe
biden
that's a shift that didn't even exist uh
three or four years ago so i'm you know
i'm proud of it
well candace owens again her book is
black out how black america can make its
second escape from the democratic
plantation
also she will be uh apparently
reportedly eulogizing cardi b at her
funeral is what i have heard
i can't just really appreciate the time
good to talk to you
thanks ben
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content